let's start with this from the
post-millennial U.S army expected to
miss recruitment goal again in 2023 oh
boy I sure hope we don't actually enter
World War III with Russia considering
we're not hitting our recruitment goals
I got it maybe there's something we can
do to drum up support among young people
and Inspire them to be the heroes of
Tomorrow to stop the madman that is
Vladimir Putin perhaps I don't know drag
queens
from from Fox News U.S Navy platformed
drag queen influencer to attract youth
to Military and hiring crisis you're
supposed to inspire young overly
testosterone-filled dudes to go want to
blow stuff up because when the military
just gave you the second Top Gun and
this is how you follow up yeah seriously
Top Gun one of the best you know
recruitment videos ever the hero's
journey and I see this story and you
know my responses to it I don't care if
you want to be a drag queen by all means
go ahead and do your thing but it's a
hobby that's not something you sign up
for to for military service to do yeah
be like talking about how many girls you
ran through or something and be like oh
yeah I got all I got I slept with 15
women last year joined the army and you
feel like me like that doesn't get I
mean yeah maybe that would get guys to
join that probably would it'd be like
really women you know dig guys in
uniform huh this is like you're you're
not getting laid you're you're going to
a show to watch watch a man dress like a
woman sing songs
I don't think that's a reason to join
the Navy just you know I see the
photograph and and all I can say is how
far we've come from when Bob Hope used
to bring Raquel Welch over to Vietnam to
entertain the troops you know and she
seemed I'm just going to say I've seen
photos and some films of that it seems
like she was well received on those
occasions why wouldn't they just stick
with that formula you know what I said
when I saw this sir everyone's
complaining about it and I was like
isn't the Navy notorious like
notoriously stereotyped for being gay
like like the whole village
yeah in the Navy and then I'm just like
this is not at all surprising to me but
like we'll just play to it it'll be fine
but but in all seriousness when we're
seeing recruitment shortages it is kind
of alarming that they're like I know
what's going to make what's going to
make young men want to sacrifice their
lives for the United States drag queens
one less than one percent of the
population I think they're just trying
to give dry cream Queens work you know
they're trying to say like we have the
surplus of drag queens that they can do
anything they can recruit for the
military and they can read to your kids
they can do it all you should be excited
to have a drag queen in your
neighborhood what they ought to be doing
is indoctrinate kids via video games
they got to give really awesome VR or
free video games free download make it
so addictive and awesome and then be
like join the military they had these
video games yeah America's Army but now
imagine you get Call of Duty six or
whatever number they're on and it's like
the story starts and the guy's like I
was on a ship when Harpy Daniels did a
performance and then you're watching a
drag queen and you're like I I don't I
don't feel inspired to die like I want
to go to war to save my country you know
what you know what you know what the
male power fantasy is more like if they
had a guy just like Spider-Man it'd
probably be a lot better literally have
a guy just like Spider-Man and do a
backflip would be better recruitment
than a drag queen this brings to mind uh
the statement of uh Mike Huckabee when
he was one of the candidates against
Donald Trump in 2016 and they still were
having large debates with the whole
field of candidates and Huckabee said on
that occasion something fairly close to
this the United State's military is not
a laboratory for social experimentation
okay it has one Mission which is to
preserve and defend the National
Security and territorial sovereignty of
the United States and I I think I would
wait a long time if I waited for
somebody in the Pentagon to explain to
me how that photo comports with that
there there needs to be Congressional
hearings and dishonorable discharges or
or stripping of rank or something for
the people who are responsible for this
you've got you've already got the meme
of the Russian have you seen the Russian
military ad yes where it's like this
dude's all ripped and he jumps out of a
plane and then lands and you know in the
snow and he puts the mask on he's got
the gun and it's like you are going to
be a hero in Russia then you get the
American ads and it's like I have two
moms and I'm a drag queen and it's like
man you know look they may not have the
resources they may be having a hard time
with the with you know they're using old
tank now in the recycling old weapons
but we're gonna we're having a Personnel
problem yeah we literally cannot get
enough people to go to boot camp not
just because of ads like this and an
apathy but also because people don't
qualify there are more people turned
away because they are overweight or they
struggle with a mental health disorder
they have drug use problems that do not
qualify for the military I mean the dod
put out this report saying basically
it's like I want to say 200 000 people
every year that qualify to join the
military and of those around less than
10 percent actually have an interest in
joining I mean it is a minuscule
population who I really think we should
just talk to and say hey did this
commercial with the drag queen seem
appealing to you like where is the Basic
Marketing study where they gather a
bunch of people who successfully did the
thing they wanted and say would these
appeal to you if you had to do it again
because I don't think this would work
it's so profoundly offensive and it's
not so much the drag queen thing because
I'm like I don't care if people want to
do that and have you know gay men
burlesque as America man you go live
your life that you want to do what's
offensive is that they're advertising
the Navy is a silly nonsense
place to be of irresponsibility
it's like if like if made if they made a
commercial and they were like join the
Navy so that you can hang out with your
buddies and eat be you know drink beer
and watch the game I'd be like that's
also that's also bad it's not first I
think this is worse but I mean honestly
you want to dress and drag fine but not
while you're on the service you're in
uniform there maybe on your private time
that's not while you're on duty that's
the other thing there's photos of this
dude protesting and I'm like uh is he is
he allowed to do that as a Navy
serviceman protest holding up a sign for
for abortion look we can we I think we
all agree that
this is not the answer to the
recruitment problem right and so you
know there at a threshold level we
condemn those who who thought that this
somehow would be the answer to that
problem but if you really want to look
at the actual root of the problem itself
um it gets to what you said earlier I
think which is you were talking about
what's going to motivate a young person
to join the military which is an
all-volunteer institution uh to
potentially give up their lives right
give up their lives for what for
something much larger than themselves
right it has to be something larger than
themselves and as we are as a society
tearing down everything that the United
States has always historically meant
okay you're going to see fewer people
want to lay down their lives for what
remains of that definition of a country
who wants to lay down their lives for
this it's this identity thing the
military is not about establishing
personal identity it's about giving up
your personal identity for the group
well and I will say the Surgeon General
just came out with this report saying uh
we have an the next Public Health crisis
and social isolation uh do you know what
branches of the military are
successfully reaching their their quotas
it's the Marine Corps it's NASA it's
it's things that people feel like they
are part of something bigger we can
identify our problem and yet we don't
apply it to the institution that
apparently needs it most the military
recruitment the Air Force struggles uh
all reservists struggle the Army
struggles the Navy struggles but yet
something that has a really strong core
identity the Marines and again space
force they are doing okay they're not
doing great but they are making their
quotas Trump needs to get reelected and
fire all of these people just strip them
and boot them out you wanna you wanna
know what you need to make you want you
want a commercial right now you need
some real propaganda here's what you do
you make a video of a guy in Ukraine and
a Russian soldier is you know firing on
some soldiers and then the guy like
grabs a child and runs from an explosion
and then gives a child to the mother
who's crying and thank somebody's like
go go go and then the guy turns around
and runs into battle in slow motion and
it's like be the hero join the Army yeah
but it's got to be like an invasion of
Alaska and be like don't let it happen
here so anything anything better than a
guy dressing up like a woman and dancing
you know like that that that's that no
no young man is being like wow that's
why I want to go to a battlefield and
die elephant in the room man when they
discharged all these people out of the
military during this covet crisis and it
was like the most based hardcore dudes
that were like I'm not putting that you
cannot make me I'm here to serve my
country leave me alone let me do my job
and now they were just kicked out now
they're just at men and women and uh
what now now they're all pissed off the
United States like they're gonna come
back I think this is us losing the war
right you know like
says win the war before you start it
before fighting it so uh right now we
have recruitment problems and the best
they can come up with this China's like
looking at you know Xi Jinping looking
at his watch are like don't invade
Taiwan yet let's let him fester for a
little bit oh they're doing the drag
queen thing okay now we're good once we
miss military chroma goals for the fifth
year in a row then then we'll move in I
mean I feel like this is so obvious and
it's happening uh very publicly America
is such a culture exports its culture at
such a high level that there's no way
that this is not part of anyone's
calculation thinking wow they don't have
a healthy population their young people
are uh have higher rates of depression
than anyone else they are not uh looking
to join the military they are feeling
isolated they are a weak country and
therefore we know that ultimately if we
can hold on long enough we can tip the
scales in our favor like that's a very
terrifying thought I'm wondering this is
provocative thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time